[MUSIC PLAYING]
This episode of "Shots
of Awe" is brought to you
by Kay Jewelers.
Every kiss begins with K.
You know, when people talk
about the desire for happiness,
when we talk about
chasing happiness,
I think what they're
ultimately talking about
is chasing novelty.
Because it's only the new
that awakens the mind,
that fully engages
us with the world.
We become anthropologists
in the new environment.
You know, we transcend
the banality and boredom
and the trivialities
of the every day.
Normally, we trivialize
ourselves with triviality.
But when we're engorged by a
new experience, all of a sudden,
we become alive.
We feel as children.
We gawk.
We are just enraptured.
And we're always chasing that.
We're like, we want happiness.
And I think it would
help if we actually
understood what we were
saying when we say,
oh, I just want to be happy.
I just want to be happy.
What you mean is you want
to continue to explore.
You want to continue to learn.
You want to continue to discover
novel lands, new landscapes
of the mind, of
perception, of thoughts.
And this is what we mean.
We can never stop learning.
We can never stop seeking.
I think that we settle
down into these routines.
And then we wonder
why we're miserable.
And I think it's ultimately
because happiness
lives in the space of novelty.
[MUSIC PLAYING]